I'm so jealous that you guys have to
have get to have these experiences
because I I can't do that with my
parents yeah yeah right because like my
mom is like already so familiar with her
my dad's come to Japan like [__] 30
times in his lifetime so I'm just like I
don't have that like immediate you know
thing of like let me show you the
wonders of this country that I love kind
of deal yeah because it's like I've done
it with my you know friends who have
never come to Japan and stuff like that
but it's different right yeah it's
different but oh but I will say it is it
never gets old seeing someone who's
never been to Japan or never been to
Asia and just seen Japan and just like
blowing their minds at the most [__]
like senseless things ever yeah for no
apparent reason you know like when I
took like my University friends to Kyoto
for instance like my my friend just like
one time we were on our way to kilometer
and he just stopped at a [__] like a
vending machine but it wasn't just one
vending machine it was like six vending
machines all in a row and he was like
taking photos of this I'm like it's a
[__] vending machine
that we walked past like 20 of them and
he was like yeah but the six of them I'm
like
why am I taking you all the way to kill
me today they were impressed uh so if
you have a drive in Japan you stop one
of the service stations they were
impressed by the giant you've seen these
right the giant coffee machines oh yeah
yeah
massive coffee machines that make like
like kind of fresh coffee uh in like a
cup and it's all like timed and this one
has a screen showing you the coffee
just a cup it was just like okay but
they were kind of impressed by that
they're like this is pretty good
um parents also not very good with
chopsticks
um
he's better than my mum he'll probably
want those three dads oh they tried they
tried it was tough it was tough we had
um with some gyoza yeah that was kind of
tough oh there's a slippery bug yeah
yeah yeah because I was like we should
try all because my favorite girls are
placed as um
they they do uh they do the yucky girls
are the normal type and then they also
do the if you want to try they can do
the deep fried uh boiled and the normal
yeah yeah so they would mum was it was
like watching like the Looney Tunes like
moment when I'm trying to pick up the
boiled gyoza she kept slipping out
slipping us splashing in the soy sauce
and I felt so bad and I can see my mom
was getting more stressed out I'm sorry
she's like how do you get good at this
I'm like I don't remember ever being
good I don't remember ever being like
not able to do this yeah I don't know I
and I realize now that not having
Chopsticks enough not you know learning
Chopsticks does kind of I mean take a
while if you're if you've never used it
um but credits my parents they they keep
trying yeah they don't they don't they
never like ask for a knife and fork
would be like where is it yeah I
remember the first place we went to this
um yeah I brought them on knife and fork
and like I think your dad was like no I
will not admit defeats and I was like
yeah that's going his dad all right
damn yeah well I think that's the best
thing right it's like it's just the fact
that I think the one thing I always
appreciate about whenever I'm taking
people to Japan or you know wherever is
that like if if they're just like even
willing they don't even have to like it
the fact the fact that they're just
willing to participate in the culture is
like the best thing
they're trying everything and then that
you know appreciating every aspect of
the culture which I'm very fun I knew
they would but you know and you had
you're always worried you're like oh man
they you know they they don't really
care that much about Japan so yeah yeah
they wouldn't yeah well the one thing
that I think is the hardest and even for
me this is kind of tough is that
you have to resist that urge to let the
taxi driver pick up your luggage because
sometimes the Dude Looks like he's like
90. he's like half your size and he's
going to pick up your heavy ass suitcase
yeah yeah and like ah dude it's like
it's it's you can obviously pick it up
like he's fine to do it and it's like
it's sometimes just easier I'm like just
let him let him do it trust me it's
going to be so annoying if you like if
you had this problem sometimes when you
when you try to put your luggage in and
they're like no I want to do it and it's
like this whole thing of like okay oh
I've had the opposite happen where like
it was a super super old guy like frail
as [__] trying to pick up my luggage and
he like went to grab it he didn't even
like try to lift this thing up he
literally just grabbed the handle for
about two seconds and then just let go
he looked at me he's like
I'm like all right
finest drivers always want to do it for
you yeah yeah because it's supposed to
be part of like the system
I think it's like the like Asian kid in
me because my parents are like pretty
old now so I've gotten used to being
like no dad for [__] sake in your 70s
let me carry the back I always want to
do it yeah yeah so I'm like every time I
get to the taxi I'm ready for like a
little not not a fight but like I'm
ready to fight him to let me know like
give me that [__] okay get in the taxi
okay I'm a young healthy man I can do
this okay don't worry about it
yeah I mean I try to do that and if it's
if it is actually heavy I'm like dude no
yeah no don't do it yeah it's like light
I'm like all right it's okay fine yeah
of course yeah yeah because it's like
sometimes especially at least for my
parents I told them to do that because I
was like don't you're not gonna be able
to communicate with them it's gonna be
awkward just just just let them do it
yeah yeah and then also let them cook do
not do not open the doors don't close
the doors don't open the door don't
touch the doors just don't and this is
the hardest thing to tell people because
I feel like you can tell them it they
just don't they don't do it because it's
like it's it's something in your brain
it's hardwired yeah where you open the
door and you close the door to the taxi
yeah but like I was like do not touch
the doors I know you want to don't do it
they will open it for you and so they
they're kind of getting used to it and
stuff I don't get it it's it's tough
It's Time to rewire it's hard traveling
outside of Japan and unlearning that the
amount of [__] times I've traveled
out and I've just one second walk
straight out of anubra and just not
looked back yeah it's just it happens
every single time I like I've had the
officer where like I walk up to the Uber
I'm just standing in front of it just
waiting for it to open I'm just like oh
yeah yeah right yeah yeah yeah yeah
um so they're getting used to it what uh
what are you planning for to do with
them for like the rest of your time yeah
are they here for a few more days
someone just came to some nice
restaurants
golden guy uh I might I'm I'm dude I I
gotta stop drinking
I feel that my parents they like
drinking so it's like I'm like I'm like
dying but no drinking please
um yeah pretty well I realized as well
like I don't mind eating out at a nice
restaurant
um but obviously be a good sign I want
to pay for them yeah and I'm like oh my
God paying for me for a nice restaurant
every now and then is fine yeah paying
for three people for a nice restaurant
every day back back to back I'm like oh
my God you're just adding up I'm like
I'm going broke here my accountant's
asking me uh uh so what's going on
Connor how many business dinners do you
have yeah 600 on a on a tempura
restaurant color really
one of the because I'm like man you've
got to try it and I'm like ah I don't
they're only here one time I should yeah
of course okay
do you think they're going to come back
at any time yeah I think they definitely
want to go skiing yeah yeah that'll be
awesome I think I think they want to
learn how to be a bit more independent
here um It's just tough because I think
learning it's understandable learning
languages uh yeah at Old ages is hard
and I think no matter how many times I
mean because even I'm you know it's
still hard to do it
telling someone how to Sumi Masen is
hard telling him telling a British
person to see myself would you rely on
Impossible yeah and I still can't do it
we're in a bar right and you know it's
gonna be nice where they're gonna be out
without me yeah and I was like man I
gotta teach you how to swim in my sand
like you've got to just do it yeah you
gotta you gotta learn because if you
want a beer you gotta you gotta you want
to get an attention right like if you
want to be it and you want it right now
you've got to swim in my sound yeah so I
told them I was like all right try it
say Sumi Masen and so they go ah Super
Saiyan I'm like no no no louder even me
when I go when I go like see my sand
they won't hear me it's like it's gonna
be even more yeah yeah
do it and then when they come over just
say just say beeru it's okay you don't
need to say any other stuff they'll they
understand you've seen a little just say
it a little bit and they're like okay
okay and they try and
my dad's so bad at it he I could tell
him what to say here and he'll just
figure it'll all just forget the moment
yeah like no I'll just say beer one more
please and I'm like Dad
you're not gonna understand one more
because my dad's a [__] pro at
swimming lesson now like I believe like
the moment he sits down he's just seeing
about that like
across he's like he knows what's up I
don't give a [__] yeah that's good
though yeah that's Pro super message
yeah I can't imagine my parents being
able to learn that my parents are the
most like reserved people on this on
this planet yeah my mom's got this book
that's Japanese phrases book and she's
using it sometimes I don't know how well
it's working out first right uh she says
it's working well I've been teaching
them like the uh phrases that need to be
used aside I'm like I try to
well at one time I I told them I was
like hey come you know I was like
because I was like hey come come to my
apartment building I'll come at your
side because they were staying super
close by and so
um I go down to my apartment building
and they're they're just talking to
someone to a Japanese person outside my
apartment building what the [__] are
they doing
so I go out and this is a woman looking
really confused and then I'm guessing my
mom was trying to confirm that this was
the address and I was like Mom I was
like I was like I see myself
and then so then she she'd laugh and I
was like whatever don't don't talk to
people thinking they're not gonna
they're not gonna speak any English what
are you doing especially in Tokyo
it was it was very wholesome but I was
like oh god oh no they're they've been
here like two days and they were like
confronting strangers I was like oh God
your mom just whips out the book it's
like it's my time and I was like oh my
god oh no I don't know
it's so cute